wir sind wieder an einem geheimen ort
mit vitali klitschko dem bürgermeister
der stadt kiew italienischen guten
mittag du siehst ich bin mittlerweile
mit einer schutzweste hier du hast
normalerweise auch eine an wie
gefährlich ist die situation
mittlerweile in der stadt wenn man
draußen unterwegs ist dann trägst du ein
helm und eine weste mittlerweile
jetzt im moment zuerst
bei uns in stadtrat
linie gibt keine russische armee
die kommen kämpfen wie gehen zurück ich
habe irgendwie der army hat richtig
starke partie gezeigt und seine
fähigkeiten ist richtig stark die ganze
bevölkerung hier ist unterstützt unsere
und eine wahnsinnig patriotismus jetzt
indurain jeder
hasst putin jede ist sehr sehr
patriotisch für die reine und soviel
heute ständig mein telefon ist richtig
schon heiß von anrufen leute fragen der
wollen waffen wir wollen unserem land
verteidigen unsere stadt die partie und
wollte er ist sehr viel spaß betrifft
situationen innenstadt sehr viele
gruppen der richtige gruppe der
richtigen gruppen
sehr viele nicht sehr viel aber
teilweise schon vorher in stat dass wege
man muss aufpassen
deswegen schuss des werks für richtige
entscheidungen beim käse drauf bitter
die dennoch es ist so dass russland in
den außen ringen der stadt so scheint es
zumindest immer mehr die kontrolle
gewinnt zumindest und russland hat
gesagt dass die zivilisten die stadt
verlassen sollten dass die kirche
verlassen soll ich will dir mal aktuelle
bilder zeigen die mein kollege peter
hell gerade am hauptbahnhof hier gefilmt
hat hier siehst du diese bilder von der
flucht das ist der hauptbahnhof 4 du
siehst wie menschenmassen hier in den
bahnhof gehen und die versuchen in einem
der letzten züge zu kommen die es raus
gibt aus kiew war russland sagt
zivilisten sollten die stadt sofort
verlassen das ist tatsächlich ein
massenandrang dort am bahnhof hier
siehst du diese massen die hoch strömen
dort raus wie ist die situation hier
sehr mehrheit dass es frauen kinder
ältere leute
deswegen sehe ich die person das ist
jetzt ständig leute so etwas noch nie
erlebt immer selbstständig dass sie alle
sind sinnlos und
deswegen deswegen
ich verstehe jede keine wirklich keine
viele solche bilder erleben schreckliche
bilder was jetzt verbreiten in internet
deswegen deswegen alle sind
unsicher weil er in russland hat gesagt
die bären zivile bevölkerung nicht aber
darum haben wir bald schon beispiele in
unserer stadt waren verkehrten in eine
hochhäuser getroffen und sehr viele
leute verletzt
was bedeutet das dass russland jetzt
sagt zivilisten sollen die stadt
verlassen wir haben bei vergangenen
kriegen erlebt dass die russische armee
dass platini putin nicht davor
zurückschreckt auch große raketensysteme
einzusetzen wir haben tief gesehen dass
dort die innenstadt bombardiert worden
es giesst du davon aus dass das jetzt
der anfang einer grösseren offensive ist
dass russland jetzt noch schlimmere
waffen einsetzen wird wenn sie sagen die
zivilisten sollen jetzt sofort die stadt
verlassen
schwierig ihren kopf um russische
präsentieren zu gehen das ist
mann mann mann ist gestern das macht hat
nicht alle tassen stand ich weiß nicht
welchen begriff muss sich ergeben zu
beschreiben wie man zum solche ideen
kommt ukraine zu angreifen weil wir
waren niemals aggressiv gegen keiner
land wir sind eine friedliche erfolg
friedliches land und sie haben einen
wunsch gehabt dass es immer in frieden
zu leben und jetzt ein trick dass es das
ist ein traum für alle
ist ich kann nicht genau beantworten die
frage beantworten ob ich nicht sehr viel
ständig putin hat eine wahnsinnige
vernichtungswaffen in verschiedener
kaliber
sogar
atomraketen ich hoffe er wird nicht dass
alles benutzen was bringt schaden für
eines findet sich friedlicher land und
für eine friedliche von für menschen
aber wie so was
keine ich kann nicht sagen was gut war
was
du als bürgermeister bisher zuständig
nicht nur für die zivile verteidigung
sondern vor allem auch für die
humanitäre lage wie es momentan die
humanitäre lage in kiew in den
krankenhäusern wie ist es mit der
versorgung mit nahrungsmitteln auch mit
medikamenten
weil dies die gebrochen
und ist kein geheimnis hierzu moment für
die menschen hat die lebensmittel
medikamenten aber schon wir haben
verschiedene signale dass es der leute
alle allem arktis zu soweit ist
geflüchtet
zu kaufen ist schwierig und schwierig
und manchmal die menschen fragen wo
können wir das mittel zu bekommen also
gibt es schon ein areal das ist dass es
willkommen und denke ich mal ab
die nächsten tage dass wir schon mit
lebensmitteln und medikamenten
die ganze infrastruktur begann service
für alltag für jeden vom geber- anwohner
ist schon nicht wie vor einer woche
jetzt man muss selbst kümmern wo es
wasser kriegen oder lebensmitteln oder
medikamenten oder service
will will glaubst du das ist wieder eine
theoretische frage weil du hast ja
völlig recht wir können nicht in den
kopf von wladimir putin aber die
russische kriegsstrategie war auch in
der vergangenheit schon öfter in einer
richtung dass man versucht eine stadt
einzukreisen und ein zu zirkeln und dann
dafür zu sorgen dass eben nahrungsmittel
nicht mehr durchkommen medikamente nicht
mehr durchkommen um dann die stadt dazu
zu bewegen den präsidenten dich dazu
aufzugeben ist dass die taktik
hoffe dass es von russischer seite das
erste steht nicht das ist die frage eher
sagen dass schlechte regierung aber das
ist okay aber jede bude ist dagegen jede
ukraine ist unterstützt durch eine
unterstufe regierung unter
seiner regie geführt
gesehen also wurde vom waldimir putin
dass er hat eine realität vorbei erzählt
der nationalisten erzählt der nazis
sonja sein wie schon sein dass jetzt
sind wir wie nazis
dass
sie verstehen nicht darüber spricht er
aber sehr viele leute in russland
glauben an weil propaganda funktioniert
ziemlich stark und denke ich mal das
weil ich die entscheidung russia today
ergebnisse vorstellen einfach eine
zertifizierung hat ein budget mehr als
hauptstadt von mehr als zwei milliarden
dollar nur ein fachgeschäft von russia
today weil medien ist eine wichtige
waffe in hände der russische diktator
und sehr viele russen glauben dass es
hier nationalisten dass narzissten das
ist deswegen auch gute sachen um die
bekommen keine richtige information
und aberglaube ich mehr und mehr wurde
wird nachdenken und und zu sehen die
ganze welt dagegen ganze welt du hast
auch natürlich alte freunde aus russland
von der ganzen welt natürlich wie
glaubst du wie sehr kann putin unter
druck geraten jetzt im eigenen land wir
sehen dass die wirtschaftssanktionen
wirken wir erleben dass die deutschen
sanktionen wirken es gibt keine flieger
mehr rubel ist im freien fall die werte
werden dort vernichtet glaubst du das
macht druck auf ihn dass der krieg
beendet wird auf jeden fall er muss
nicht du wer seine produkte gegen lr
mohsen denken ob er seinem volk und
wissen sie was das es war nur für zwei
das ist die jede geschäfte mit russland
vormachen könne sich vorstellen die
ganze geld was bringt bekommt russische
regierung von europa investieren nicht
den usern ist hier nicht den erfolg die
investieren im militär in seiner armee
und danach so passiert was erleben in du
kleine bitterli viele menschen in
deutschland kennen dich du bist ein idol
für viele menschen geworden durch 2014
aber auch schon als boxweltmeister
zusammen mit seinem bruder wladimir und
jetzt beide 24 7 hier unterwegs was
macht das mit dir persönlich wie geht es
dir dabei das zu erleben in deiner stadt
in deinem land
schon jetzt leidet mehr über mein bruder
ist dabei und immer dabei
für unsere mutter
hatte riesige sorgen und
mama mach keine sorgen ich gehe ja um
jüngere und jugendliche
ältere und deswegen versuchen wir unsere
mutter beruhigen foto susi ist sehr
gut wunderbar zu haben kann sich mit dem
darüber diskutiert dass es eine alptraum
wenn jemand erzählt mehr noch vor wochen
dass etwas passiert in meine stadt leere
straßen das ist borken stehen also
straße man darf nicht fahren das ist
die touristengruppen
laufenden die stadt sie die die die
moniert der infrastruktur besonders die
bombardierungen
in
der frist die die häuser
bisher ist es schwierig zu begleiten
denke ich mal wir brauchen noch ein
bisschen zeit zu einfach zu verstehen so
etwas zu erleben
ich habe eine gefühlte kein bruder ich
habe mich mit ihm diskutiert dass es
seine wir sind im kino eine fantasie
oder horror movie aber das ist realität
dass es harte realität und unsere wand
um meine aufgabe ja so schnell wie
möglich an menschen zu helfen weil alle
kennen mich in meinem start und die
leiter von der stadt und alle fragen
während wasserwegen service wegen
krankenhäuser krankenbett
aber jetzt mal mehr und das ziemlich
schwierig wir versuchen qualität das ist
alles so recherchen schnell ist wie
möglich dass es menschen zur
unterstützung um noch gleichzeitig
unsere stadt zu verteidigen
dennoch fragen sich viele menschen in
deutschland auch die fans sind von euch
beiden wie gefährlich ist das für euch
wladimir putin wird dich hassen weil du
für das stehst was den westen ausmacht
du hast am altar angestanden
demonstriert du bist du hast in
deutschland amerika gewohnt haben hat
wladimir putin ist auf dich abgesehen
ich bin zu hause
das ist meiner stadt ich fühle mich hier
wohl
ich
so viel habe so viele energien
investiert das ist meine vision zu
implementieren das ist die stadt geht
muss richtig mit europäische standard
der eine sich schon irgendwie
historische stadt zu ändern zum guten zu
wenden und
deswegen
keine kampf vom mehr wegnehmen meinen
traum zum erst zweites und wieso mein
land und drittens an zu haben bevor ich
bin zu hause davor ermordet zu werden
jeder fonds irgendwann steht
als
ehemaliges how platte ich habe eine
habe ich gespürt
wenn mein mann braucht mein leben da
muss ich mein land beteiligen und wärme
90 wird mit lebend sein
vitali ein ausblick zum schluss auf die
nächsten tage die nächsten nächte jetzt
gerade friedensverhandlungen hast du
irgendeine hoffnung dass etwas dabei
rauskommen kann und wie wird das
weitergehen wir nichts dabei raus kommt
wie lange wird sich hier verteidigen
können wie lange wird es dauern bis
russland tatsächlich die stadt umzingelt
hat danke für die frage das ist sehr
wichtig während haben wir
unterstützung von deutschland danke für
alle wenn du keine aber gesehen dass es
tausend und hunderttausend millionen von
menschen gestern eher auf die straßen
gegangen und protestiert gegen und
menschlicher aktivität russischen
aktivitäten was passiert und in unserem
land ich danke von ganzem herzen aber
von eurer meinung von hoher präzision
abhängige suppen von unserem land da
werden wir werden kämpfen für unsere
zukunft für unser land und wären
sie unterstützung uns politisch
moralisch da kann der da was können
deutsche tun die das jetzt die uns
zuschauern ihr gerade bei bild live wo
wir in einem geheimen ort hier sitzen
was kann an zuschauer tun soll er
spenden soll er auf die straße gehen ja
jetzt wollen wir und ich bin nicht auf
die straßen zu gehen das ist eine
meinung zu sagen
an russische wirtschaft an alle rufs und
das ist die berufung müssen aufwachen
und wir stehen das ist alles was
passiert das ist keine moderne welt das
ist die methoden von
mittelalter
ich möchte
bestimmt sie brauchen eine gute
unterstützung und bestimmt wir brauchen
lebensmittel gestimmt wir brauchen wir
die gemeinden arbeiten aber die wisi
compact wir durch die politiker aber die
wichtigste dass es mit herz und verstand
moralische unterstützung dabei mit ton
zu sein das ist sehr wichtig und dafür
auch den gedanken jetzt hat deutschland
diese harten sanktionen über die wir
seit seitdem wir uns kennen 2013/14
wertes mal dampf und dann der krim und
der ost ukraine die du immer gefordert
hat jetzt wird das umgesetzt und olaf
scholz hat sich plötzlich um 180 grad
gewendet der bundeskanzler und hat eine
harte rede gegen russland gehalten und
diese sanktion gegen moskau behalten und
boutiquen und die sanktion umgesetzt wie
nimmst du die deutsche politik war
ich freue mich sehr viel mut aufgebracht
ja die hat es nie geglaubt
ehrlich keine kam glauben so etwas kann
passieren aber die jede aggressiver bild
jetzt muss eine antwort bekommen haben
es geht nicht und deswegen danke für
jede durch die politik endlich mal
gestanden was bedeutet russischem
bayerische ambitionen
was ist vitali wir haben gestern erlebt
dass wladimir putin über atomwaffen
gesprochen hat über provokation des
westens was ist wenn wladimir putin
nicht mehr zurechenbar ist also uns zu
rechnen ist
was passiert dann auf dieser welt
aber die ganze geld kam nicht auf rief
olympia stehen
wir muss entsprechen die muss so
überzeugen aber wissen sie was sehr sehr
wichtig denke ich
wenn er hört nicht besten glaube ich in
sehr kurzer zeit
fängt an zu hören osten ich meine die
seinem buch wer wird hier stehen für sie
dort festnehmen wie den straßen wird
übrigens sanktion das ist nur der russin
denkt wie so bekommen sie keine
westliche produkte sowie sowie glauben
keine westliche service die so die
modernen welt steht nicht mehr mit
gesichtslos dass es druck von innen war
von russland in ufa muss einen trug
aufwachsen gegen polieren weil er muss
seine
idee stoppen es geht nicht dass es alle
gemeinsam muss er erklären oder zeugen
und
sondern das unmenschliche aktivitäten
seit zweite weltkrieg im europäischen
raum so etwas noch nie passiert wie
sieht dein tag heute aus der nacht heute
aus was machst du
die letzten tage habe ich hoffe sehr
wenig und
sehr streng sehr viele termine sehr
viele kommunikation zwischen
zivilisten armee
die der territorialen verteidigung und
dazu die verteidigung noch service an
menschen zu geben sehr viel telefoniert
mit westlichen partner mit sehr viele
politiker
damit menschen mit bewerb der
haben hoffen sie brauchen hilfe von mehr
sehr stinkt mir gesagt dass wir zeit
haben wir nie gehabt so stein gezeigt
hast du zeit mit seinen kindern zu
sprechen wie viele sorgen macht sich
deine familie in der ukraine sind
[Musik]
gestern habe ich nun wieder mit meine
kleine gesprochen mit kleinste
alles schon nicht mehr als 16 weil 17
aber
wenig zeit sogar sogar mit gewinn zu
sprechen und alle haben so schicken sms
europas hat sich auch bis zum
papa pass auf dich auf sagen die kinder
von vitali klitschko in diesen tagen und
damit gebe ich zurück nach berlin vielen
dank
vielen herzlichen dank an der paul
ronzheimer und 1 vitali klitschko von
hier bürgermeister der städte gedanken
sind mit euch beiden dankeschön fast
gleichauf